herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
von der hallo deutsche schule
im heutigen video sprechen wir über das
thema geld und verraten de tipps wie man
geld sparen kann
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
von der hallo deutsche schule
im heutigen video sprechen wir über das
thema geld und verraten de tipps wie man
geld sparen kann
so passt gut auf
viel spaß und film ab
hallo paul hallo paul hallo anna hallo
anna was für ein zufall dass ich dich
hier treffe was für ein zufall dass ich
dich hier treffe wir haben uns lange
nicht mehr gesehen
wir haben uns lange nicht mehr gesehen
wie geht es dir denn so wie geht es dir
denn so du siehst ein wenig besorgt aus
du siehst ein wenig besorgt aus ja was
für ein zufall
ja was für ein zufall
ehrlich gesagt geht es mir gerade nicht
so gut
so gut was ist denn los
was ist denn los
kann ich dir irgendwie helfen kann ich
dir irgendwie helfen
ich bin auf der suche nach einer zweiten
arbeit
warum suchst du eine zweite arbeit warum
suchst du eine zweite arbeit
es ist mir etwas unangenehm darüber zu
sprechen
das muss es nicht das muss es nicht
erzählt schon erzählt schon na gut
möchtest du dich hinsetzen
na gut möchtest du dich hinsetzen gerne
gerne
also dann erzähl mal wo drückt der schuh
[Musik]
das geld von meiner arbeit reicht nicht
aus um meine ausgaben zu bezahlen
das geld von meiner arbeit recht nicht
[Musik]
am ende des monats bin ich immer auf
null
ich muss dringend mehr geld verdienen
8 paul ich weiß genau wie es dir geht 8
paul ich weiß genau wie es dir geht mir
ging es noch vor ein paar monaten
genauso wie dir
mir ging es noch vor ein paar monaten
genauso wie dir wirklich wirklich und
was hast du dann gemacht
und was hast du dann gemacht hast du dir
auch eine zweite arbeit gesucht hast du
dir auch eine zweite arbeit gesucht
nein ich habe im casino den jackpot
gewonnen
gewonnen und jetzt kann ich tun und
lassen was ich will
und jetzt kann ich tun und lassen was
ich will ist das nicht toll ist das
nicht toll was du hast wirklich geld im
kasino gewonnen was du hast wirklich
geld im kasino gewonnen
das ist ja wahnsinn herzliche
gratulation an das ist ja wahnsinn
herzliche gratulation anna nein paul das
war nur ein scherz
nein paul das war nur ein scherz
das war jetzt gemein von dir das war
jetzt gemein von dir jetzt erzählt schon
jetzt erzählt schon hast du einen guten
rat für mich wie ich geld sparen kann
hast du einen guten rat für mich wie ich
geld sparen kann
ich habe sogar fünf tipps für dich ich
habe sogar fünf tipps für dich wie du
weißt sind die schweizer weltmeister im
geld sparen
wie du weißt sind die schweizer
weltmeister im geld sparen
am besten schreibst du gleich mit damit
du nichts davon vergisst am besten
schreibst du gleich mit damit du nichts
davon vergisst
spar tipp nummer eins
läge etwas geld am anfang des monats zur
seite
wenn du bis am ende des monates wartest
bleibt oft kein geld mehr übrig
plötzlich flattert noch eine rechnung
ins haus
und schnell ist das konto wieder leer
ohne das geld gespart wurde
lege deshalb am anfang des monats etwas
geld zur seite
spar tipp nummer zwei erstelle ein
budget
er stelle ein budget
mit einem festgelegten haushaltsbudget
kann man richtig geld sparen
oft hat man am ende des monats kein geld
mehr in der tasche
ohne dass man merkt wohin das geld
geflossen ist
alles was man weiß ist dass das konto
leer ist
ein haushaltsbudget hilft dir den
überblick über die einnahmen und
ausgaben zu bewahren
ein haushaltsbudget hilft dir den
überblick über die einnahmen und
ausgaben zu bewahren
das klingt nicht sehr spannend
zum glück gibt es praktische apps welche
das budgetieren einfach machen
spar tipp nummer drei vermeide spontane
einkäufe
vermeide spontane einkäufe
die meisten von uns kennen das
attraktive werbung verleitet uns dinge
zu kaufen welche wir gar nicht brauchen
und dann ärgern wir uns weil am ende des
monats wieder kein geld zum sparen übrig
ist
und dann ärgern wir uns weil am ende des
monats wieder kein geld zum sparen übrig
ist
überlege dir ob der kauf wirklich nötig
überlege dir ob der kauf
wirklich nötig ist
eine andere möglich
iss deinen wunsch auf einen zettel zu
schreiben
eine andere möglichkeit ist deinen
wunsch auf einen zettel zu schreiben
den zettel legst du dann zur seite
nach sieben tagen holst du ihn wieder
heraus
möchtest du das produkt jetzt immer noch
kaufen
dann los
spar tipp nummer vier
koche selber anstatt auszugehen
im restaurant zu essen ist oft sehr
teuer
gemeinsam mit freunden kannst du ein
schönes gericht kochen
wenn jeder gast etwas mitbringt spart
ihr noch mehr geld
gemeinsam mit freunden kannst du ein
schönes gericht kochen
wenn jeder gast etwas mitbringt spart
ihr noch mehr geld
außerdem ist selbst gekochtes essen
nicht nur günstiger sondern auch
gesünder
außerdem ist selbst gekochtes essen
nicht nur günstiger sondern auch
gesünder
[Applaus]
spar tipp nummer fünf sei clever beim
einkaufen
sei clever beim einkaufen
günstigsten kannst du kurz vor
ladenschluss einkaufen
am günstigsten kannst du kurz vor
supermärkte bieten ihre produkte kurz
vor schließung oft günstiger an
und weil supermärkte am sonntag
geschlossen haben
lohnen sich große einkäufe besonders am
samstag
weil supermärkte am sonntag geschlossen
haben
lohnen sich große einkäufe besonders am
samstag
extra spar tipp
läge regelmäßig kleingeld zur seite
niemand trägt gerne viele münzen mit
sich herum
erleichtere deinen geldbeutel und lasse
die münzen zu hause
eher leichtere deinen geldbeutel und
lasse die münzen zu hause
du wirst sehen dass auf diese weise
schnell ein beachtlicher betrag
zusammenkommen kann
du wirst sehen dass auf diese weise
schnell ein beachtlicher betrag
zusammenkommen kann
vielen dank an das waren ein paar sehr
hilfreiche ratschläge
das waren ein paar sehr hilfreiche
ratschläge kein problem paul kein
problem paul das habe ich gerne gemacht
das habe ich gerne gemacht viel erfolg
damit viel erfolg damit
waren unsere tipps nützlich für dich
wie versuchst du geld zu sparen
schreibe es in die kommentare
[Musik]
vergiss nicht das video zu leiten
kommentiere und abonniere unseren kanal